cette chaleur bien inhabituel d'abord
pour ce mois de septembre le thermomètre
a grimpé au dessus des 30 degrés
aujourd'hui des températures élevées qui
vont se poursuivre tout au long de la
semaine
le niveau 2 du plan alerte canicule a
été d'ailleurs activé dans les yvelines
entre plaisir de prolonger l'été
inquiétudes pour la planète légumes en
courtois se sont confiés ce micro ce
midi au micro d' astrid berges r&d
l'honneur sinoquet alors bas côté ça
fait du bien mais on se dit que si la
planète va bien s'il fait 30° au mois de
septembre et et qu'il faut faire quelque
chose pour la planète c'est sympa on
peut on peut aller manger dehors prendre
du temps avec les amis c'est très
agréable surtout en ces temps de rentrée
là c'est très agréable de voir se
promener et profiter un peu avant la
phase de l'hiver qui va être longue
on est bien dehors mais après c'est
vraiment préoccupant pour la planète ou
fin et faut faire beaucoup de choses
quand même pour changer tout ça ça va
pas des plus agréable de manger dehors
comme intérieure ça peut oublier la
rentrée d'habitude on sort plutôt les
parapluies les aider les imperméables
acpo si ça peut arriver
donc c'est plus agréable de prolonger
l'été